okay here's the cake I'm unsure anything
about anything it is warm pure birth
inspired inspired by the film this looks
just like a date on Pinterest it doesn't
really look much like the picture that I
tried hate Pinterest because everybody's
like look at me I'm over here like
colony is red and green what kind of
world are you living in what world is
this this is not working what the hell
are you doing why are you scrunching up
like that that's all right I love coffee
I generally you guys know that I'm
actually trying to make this cool and
I'm hoping that I'm slightly succeeding
look at this
yeah looks good though right yeah Oh
Justine now they're stuck together oh
sure we might need oh my god I am so
sorry
I'm so sorry I thought I had a handle on
that and I cannot I did not have a
handle on that you cook the rice no I
just have in all the walks well it
tastes like lemonade to me God is this
disgusting get that out of here okay oh
you're coming here oh crap I do this
every time
oops so they turned out okay oh no my
buns are browning my buns are burning
that looks like disgusting Wow
drop Oh
shop so I add something extra to this
all of the sprinkles I'm gonna burn the
sugar I bet this is probably not gonna
go very well something's gonna go wrong
this looks actually so good I can't
believe this might actually work out
holy crap this actually worked out way
better than I thought
I hate softening the butter is melting
extremely fast bad news that's like
that's boiling butter oiling butter you
dumb idiot it's so watery I actually
don't know what's gonna happen
although we're both idiots oh god I'm
greased up like a little piglet look
this look like when I get all of it
stupid lid just pops off this is a
really great measurement I also don't
wanna mess this up because I think this
is gonna be really good it was a
sugar-free and fat-free that sounds like
it's gonna taste like trash oh damn oh
okay oh okay you're done now wait wait
wait no no no oh boy that's not good
oh boy wow wow wow wow this is my first
time using a hand mixer
there's got to be a better way to cut
this but we'll work on that for the
second time around it also never cut a
peach before if you're wondering how
I've made it through my life this far
I'm actually wondering the same thing
half of a lime sliced well this is half
of the lime I sliced it Oh God
whoo this is gross oh these are the
things that we're not gonna make sure it
looks like a tablespoon after grease and
dust with flour I don't like that you
could just eat your way around never
really garlic before so this is gonna be
just get out of there I apologize to
those who are here for lack of measuring
measuring measuring measuring tell me
how you say it
hey got a knife I work I've got a snake
I've got a bloodbath I'm not a pumpkin
I've got one valve and you can use
really any method that you want but I
feel like in my small feeble mind this
to me looks like the best idea
oh god I've already made a mess oh shoot
I have to cook this I have to cook it
this roadkill
I think that's about as good as we're
gonna get
I put too much mint